that's an important thing i think we
should bring up the
the reason that we're not sitting
together right now doing this podcast
is because you're not allowed to leave
the state
yeah um so i if the the story behind
that is
my mayor and city council
are fraud waste and abuse of government
resources taxpayer money
they're doing something called using
something called tax increment financing
which uh if you look into it it's taking
possible future taxes and
using that money now and then increasing
the taxes to pay it back
later well they've been giving money
to out-of-state developers and people
coming in from out of state
there's a guy from wisconsin named nick
jacota
whose father um made
money by selling faulty medical
equipment
and then was uh exiled from wisconsin
while running for congress because he
was so corrupt
um he's here in missoula and he wants to
be this music
mogul he wants to make missoula some
sort of music venue place
um and the city council was going to
give him 17 million dollars in
tax money to build a
failed business that was going to be
under his control for 70 years
and we were going to pay it back after
70 years well
also we've got a bank called stockman's
bank that was given 4.4 million dollars
in tax money to build their building
and the first interstate bank of montana
was given 1.5 million dollars of
taxpayer money to build their their bank
when they could have done it themselves
right the whole point of being a
business person is to make those
investments and build the business
yourself
and um it's increased the the cost of
living in missoula
is is has skyrocketed since engine has
become mayor
and uh there are 120 plus houses on the
market and
only 17 of them are below
you broke up for that last part would
you say they're 17 17 houses
that are uh below a million dollars
on the market right now in my own
hometown and the
median income in missoula is less than
40 000 whoa
so i yelled at the mayor for basically
stealing
money and giving it to the wealthy like
the sheriff of nottingham
and the they put me in jail for a month
so uh how did you yell at the mayor
where were you how
city council i was at a city council
meeting okay
and i told them so i told him the story
i don't know so i make a lot of biblical
references because i
i was trained in the biblical mythology
but uh king david is my favorite
biblical character
and king david is the man who's called a
man after god's own heart
the only one in the bible in fact called
that and he was an adulterer a liar a
scoundrel but he was king and the reason
why he was called a man after god's own
heart because he was repentant
and the prophet nathan at uh
who was the prophet during that time
came into david and told the story he
says
there was once a rich man with 99 sheep
and a poor man with one
and the rich man was having guests come
over to his house so he goes out to his
land and sees his 99
sheep but he sees that the poor man's
one sheep is greater than all of his 99
so he takes the poor man's sheep and
serves him up to his guest and leaves
the poor man destitute with nothing
and i was like do you guys understand
this and we've been going i've been
going to the city council meetings for
about two months at that time
and they didn't listen they were all
bought off they were all
there for popularity contest they were
they [ __ ] up
missoula like they literally have [ __ ]
up missoula
um jackson construction company a
developer
has the mayor angen has been giving them
money
and got his apartment his condominium
under uh market price for working with
them through a
an llc a shell company
and so i exposed all this and so i was
like do you understand the story
do you understand what it is that i'm
telling you and
they just kind of were like they're on
their cell phones they were on the
computer and i was like you are that
rich man
and i yelled at him and i was like you
have stolen
from my home you have stolen from my
community
like my grandparents had to sell their
family home my grandparents had to sell
their family home
my uncle had to sell my
great-grandparents home because they can
no longer afford to pay the tax the
property taxes here
you know we've been here since the 70s
my grandpa
led hellgate high school to its first
state champion
legendary my grandpa has taken hell gate
hell gate high school yeah wow what a
great name where uh
actually where uh the city of missoula
the entryway to the city of missoula is
called hellgate canyon
really yeah that's amazing there's a
beach right down the street from here
that we call the gates of hell that we
call the gates of hell because it's
junction 666. that's cool
yeah it's funny yeah it's called
hellgate canyon because uh
when the settlers were coming through
the native americans would kill
all the settlers and just leave their
corpses oh
[ __ ] yeah yeah holy [ __ ]
yeah um so like
like my family my mom has been a teacher
my grandpa was a teacher
at hellgate by a biola biology teacher
my mom has been a teacher in the montana
school district for
almost 25 years now i was going to be a
teacher my grandfather was a minister
helped build a couple churches here also
my
my father is a rancher who owns ten
thousand acres of uh
40 miles from here my family has deep
deep deep connections here
and people are leaving because they
can't afford to live here anymore
because wealthy people from out of state
are coming in
and buying the politicians
um and the people that are uh the slum
lords that are here
they they force people to pay exorbitant
rents but pretty much all the people
that live here live in
squalor at their slums
my sister moved out of a place that this
guy
he has multiple boats he has four
wheelers
and snowmobiles and a large truck and he
could barely be
bothered to go and fix anything that
they had wrong with their apartment
like their apartment was falling apart
um and so i yelled at the mayor and
they jailed me for
inciting uh improper influence of a
government official
is what they said they rested you right
there on the spot
uh no they put a lot of warrant for my
arrest and i
turned myself in because i was like you
guys are [ __ ] stupid
like this is so dumb they jailed they
put me in jail for a month
um and it's been a year it's now it'll
be a year and a half
before i get my trial uh
and the reason being is because they
don't have anything like
uh they're they're they're
one of the things that people don't know
is that um
kalispell montana is actually a hub for
drone
development and there's a lot of money
and people wanting to put me in jail and
punish me for what i did
right and if they put me in jail then i
lose all my medical benefits from the va
um which is how i survive right now so
if i go to jail then i get all my
benefits taken away if they convict me
of a felony i'm no longer eligible for
benefits and i'm basically going to be a
poor man on the street
they can silence you effectively yeah um
do you think that do you think this is
specifically tied to your whistle
blowing and speaking out about the drone
programs and all this oh
absolutely the guy who uh the guy who
got me
into speaking out at the city council
meeting
he actually told me that i was he's like
you're probably gonna go to jail and i
was like i'm not gonna do anything to go
to jail
um but the guy set me up the guy was a
government agent that was
specifically set me up to go to jail he
told me that i was gonna go to jail
and i know that there's a lot of people
out there that are [ __ ] pissed at me
they want me to suffer they want to
punish me
and they're pissed off that i haven't
faced any consequences for my
actions but you're going to punish
someone for telling the truth when
it's these people who are fraud waste
and abuse of government resources
they're murdering people like the
consequences for that
are more dire than having the truth
revealed
because if the consequences you know for
you know stealing money from the
community it means the community is
undermined
we look at what happened with the
coronavirus like we should have had a
pandemic team in place to show us
and tell us how we're supposed to deal
with the situation
and have proper guidelines but we have
people dying all over the place we have
hospitals that are overrun and and
ceos that are well we can't make money
off of this so they're
they're writing people is getting the
coronavirus but they're not taking care
of people because they're getting money
from the government
like bear money from the government but
they're so
greedy that they don't want to spend any
of that money on what it's actually
supposed to be spent on
right and i had thought that my own
reputation
would save me from dire consequences
because
hey i'm not sitting here trying to
incite violence i'm not sitting here
trying to attack people like i'm
standing my ground
which is what you're supposed to do
right i don't
i will defend myself and i will defend
others
but i will first make sure that if you
are going to be in these positions of
power that you will i don't want their
job i want them to do their job right
because if they don't do their job right
i suffer the consequences
my community suffers the consequences
you know
and that's not what i want to do i've
traveled all over the world i've seen
what happens
in places like egypt and europe
and even other places in the united
states where corrupt politicians just
build concrete
of cities and they don't take care of
their people there's
homelessness everywhere mayor engen ran
on this
in 2012 he ran on this uh
to get to lower homelessness in missoula
well homelessness has increased like 400
percent in missoula
and they've done nothing to to elevate
right and so we have all these wealthy
people coming in uh the person
that he is grooming to run for mayor
next is a woman from wisconsin named
gwen jones
and um gwen jones
is what she has done anytime anyone goes
to city council
and talks out at city council she looks
them up on the internet
and will go to the place that they work
with and get them fired
she'll be like if you don't if your work
if you don't fire your worker for what
he's done i'm gonna ruin your business
she'll do that you know she was the
reason she
and a guy named brian von losberg are
the reason
why i was put in jail in the first place
because
they um they actually found my stalkers
videos of me
and used my soccer's videos as a reason
to put me away
uh which is exciting to me because now
my stalker is going to have to um
uh admit in the court of law whether or
not he's what he was saying was true or
not
and this guy has been inciting violence
against me
he's actually gotten my he's actually
tried to get veterans to come and kill
me and my family
i